[Musique]
sept des opérateurs de l'eau que nous
recevons dans son caddie ce matin au dc
et dans ce studio son directeur général
gilles christine bonjour bonjour maurice
bonjour à la martinique et permet -
bonjour appuyé à tous les abonnés de
l'acacia merci en dc société de gestion
de l'eau et d'assainissement sur la zone
centre sur le territoire de la cacem jus
de christine si on écoute bien michel
grand c'est le directeur de la société
martiniquaise des eaux d'ici est un
mauvais payeur
l'asm vous a fourni 12 millions de
mètres cubes d'eau depuis des années
mais vous ne payez pas cette facture
estimée à 10 millions d'euros mais que
vous arrive-t-il
il faut qu'on soit sérieux maurice viaud
le temps 10 millions d'euros pourquoi
pas 20 millions 30 millions 40 millions
100 millions très concrètement quand on
dit quelque chose de différent on laisse
croire encore 10 6 k o dia que des
voleurs de mauvais gestionnaires etc
le dossier très clairement tout le monde
y compris la préfecture et au courant de
cette difficulté il y a eu un groupe le
régime de travail de qui a été mis en
place par le préfet composé de services
de l'état notamment la dl ce groupe de
travail n'a pas pu avoir des documents
le zébu très tardivement moralité ce
groupe de travail et n'a jamais plus de
cobourne qui a bein de l'asm et la
question à se poser c'est pourquoi il y
un manque de transparence à l'asm
pourquoi l'asm ne font ni pas les
éléments pour que ce groupe travaille
livre sa copie au préfet la lumière des
forces l attaque
non je dis en fait qu'il faut être
honnête quand on annonce des chiffes un
groupe de travail a été constitué n'a
pas pu travailler et rendre sa copie une
facture a été p celle de 2015 sur la
base j'ai envie de dire donc de nac en
politique entre les trois présidents des
communautés d'agglomération cap dans
l'espace sud et la cacem 2 millions cent
vingt mille euros ont été payés sur
cette facture de 2015 par audi sissoko
représentant 40 centimes d'euro dans
qu'est ce qu'on nourrit comme dans une
facture par exemple celle de 2016
on nous donne entre le cap union 7
d'euros sur la base de 5 millions 300
mille mètres cubes estime moi car
applique parti ni compte imposer et
poser ses comptes et en juin 2007
et de façon de cas concrets et yo ka
mandé nous payer 87 centimes du maître
que là où dans une note que je vous
fournis keynote de didier wallon qui a
été remis au groupe de travail l'asm
elle même reconnaît dans sa dernière
page que les deux usines de directoire
et de rivière blanche qui livre la
quasi-intégralité 20 des abonnés de
saint joseph et de lamentin cette eau
est produite à 15 centimes 80 en
d'autres termes c'est monsieur d'amendé
nous 550% bénéfice pour quelques pas des
pourriels au public donc sans combat que
nous qu'estimé qui légitiment élu la
castle est élu le voit ici ne pas
quitter l'eau privé dépouillés donc
j'étais si non pas quand même rappeler
certaines certaines choses avant il y
avait le syndicat intercommunal du
centre et du sud de la martinique qui a
disparu le 31 décembre dernier
cette compétence de l'eau revient
maintenant aux communautés
d'agglomération se trouve que la cacem à
récupérer des communes de lamentin et de
saint joseph qui auparavant travaillait
avec le 6 qui est essentiellement sur le
sud et qu'il y avait des contrats passés
entre l'asm et le 6e du classement
estime tout simplement qu'un bain
puisque l'écart a repris cette
compétence à bien la audi sinatra qu au
dc et la cacem n'ont qu'à poursuivre
ceux qui avaient été signés dans un
contrat si c'était si simple
maurizio le temps pourquoi la préfecture
a considéré que ces temps de difficultés
pourquoi le préfet remis en place un
groupe de pilotage et de travail composé
de ses services pour essayer de trouver
le juste prix à payer par les abonnés de
saint joseph et et de et du lamentin
pourquoi ce groupe de travail n'a jamais
peu jusqu'à maintenant rendre sa copie
pourquoi l'asm n'a fourni aucune somme
sur transparent tout ce qu'on fait ça me
fait rire en tout cas là et ça me dit
très clairement que ao d'ici
vous percevez quand même les l'argent
demandé aux clients aux abonnés les
clients qui paient très clairement et
vous fait quoi de l'argent question
posée mais où va cet argent que
répondez-vous à l'accident jeudi à l'asm
eux qu'il faut être honnête
l'asm sait très bien qu'on le rappelle
une facture en 2015 elle ne l'a jamais
dit au dc à payer à 40 centimes de haut
2 millions cent vingt mille euros
car il n'aura mis en millions l'asm sait
très bien qu'on avait un c'est à la
caisse des dépôts et consignations les
factures de 2016 et 2017
il y au moment où je vous parle plus de
2 millions 5,2 euros consignés dans la
tente que cette difficulté soit levée
alors ce qui m'a en tout les cas un peu
étonné ses collègues c'est me sollicite
lobby l'arbitrage du préfet l'ont le
préfet y saisit depuis longtemps tous
les cas si cet arbitrage donc le prêt
sans intérêt le préfet a intérêt à aller
très vite dans ce dossier parce que le
dossier de l'eau fâche beaucoup en
martinique
je pense que sans dossier qui a une
teneur politique c'est simple comment
vais-je expliqué à cette petite dame
nous oublie le nom qui habitent même pas
500 mètres de l'usiné de rivière blanche
que l'eau ait pour but à 15 centimes 80
et que je la lui fait payer à 87
centimes ses 105 ans pour cent mais moi
j'ai envie aujourd'hui maurizio le temps
où tu as et au passé 550 pour mon
peut-on imaginer que sur une ou qui est
quand même un produit de première
nécessité constate un profit de 550 pour
cent des acteurs privés est-ce que c'est
pas dépouiller le public quelque part
cependant l'héritage de ce qui s'est
passé dans le cycle on rappelle quand
même qui est un facteur il y a déficit
de 23 millions d'euros avec avec le
cyclisme est ce que quelque part on se
souvient que les communautés
d'agglomération avait la tête qui enfle
et lorsqu ils savaient qu'ils allaient
devoir renflouer cette cette dette est
quelque part c'est là l'héritage de
cette situation à maurizio temps je
connais mes limites je suis un
technicien dont la vous poser une
question d'ordre politique donc je pense
que vous aurez un invité politique du
sud qui va être en capacité je pense
diplomate là je pense notamment au
président de l'espace sud qui va se
faire plaisir
vous expliquez les huit âge qu'il a
reçus et là il a déjà eu l'occasion il a
déjà eu l'occasion de le dire mais
lorsqu on vous entend lorsqu'on entend
d'autres personnes impliquées dans ce
dans ce milieu on a quand même
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui on demanda
au dc
deux clients des abonnés dodici de payer
la facture des autres alors moi si vous
voulez me fait réagir par rapport à la
note de monsieur didier lallement
président de la sncf a causé une note
qui donnent des informations incroyable
qui dit de façon très claire que l'
équilibre économique
j'ai envie de dire de l'eau du sud était
basé notamment sur les zones urbanisées
qui sont parenti qui prévoit un système
torsen joseph et la menthe à saint
joseph et lamentin qui prévoit un
système unique de valeurs en vente le
val de vente en gros dos excusez moi en
termes de vay de variable d'ajustement
en d'autres termes ça veut dire qu'on
n'a pas un prix de l'eau qui un prix
économiquement juste mais qui est plus
au prix de l'eau pour éviter des
augmentations du coût devrait entrer de
nous expliquer avec de jolies phrases
que finalement le but du jeu serait
demandé à saint joseph et olam entre
deux pays et l'autre du sud pour que
l'espace sud n'est pas augmenter le
tarif de ses abonnés - maka constater
c'est pas moi qui dit maurizio le temps
c'est didier va l'emprise de l'asm qui
dit clément linotte la map and i un
tableau en laye le caillou paye
d'ailleurs paris des tableaux -
martinique n'ont pas mis en rogne ont
les mains liées en français dans le
texte manque a constaté que lui a dit
que you came est un système de
solidarité d'accord qui basé en principe
que pièce et lui la cacem pas décidé et
que you came et et ses abonnés la
cassonade dans un système pendant
qu'elle considère comme étant un système
en otage en ce moment ces messieurs les
prend
les abonnés du centre en otage et faut
se comprendre que cause la légitime et
que tout élu la cacem tout élu au dc
kaboom écosystèmes talent oui et s'il
peut faire dix autres payez la junte à
10 millions d'uros à être le système
économique dure 10 6 4 ab la route maka
rappelé aux rassemblements politiques
donc s'il peut faire a dit ça n'a qu'à
penser gagnant réponse politique
en même temps on doit prendre mercredi
passé que tenir réunion communautaire et
que nous découvrons sa queue
gagner en augmentation de près de 7% de
la taxe coût de l'assainissement s'est
présenté combier de centimes à
surfacturer aux adresses e-mails sans
clavier payer alors augmentation de 6 73
pause et d'ailleurs c'est beaucoup
permettez aux mains de dieu pour qui sa
nouvelle augmentation ces messieurs
l'asm va exploiter aussi noter qu'à
exploiter aussi l'assainissement manqua
pas un exemple gadea d'un kill it à eux
quitté station d'épuration à quinze
jours ne pas dire les élus la cacem
badiane les élus au dissipa diagne les
élus la casse avait pu au 10 6 nations
unies la balle anti pétrole chaque lan
cap voilà obligée d'émettre constation
en l'état nos produits propres au
territoire joue mon point des années la
police de louvain kénogami nous que
bellac à carthage était de loin au delà
et des bouillet coyotes l'aigle et
autant de vignalet les zones qui a dit
que l'asm a mal fait travailler nos
professeurs nous les élus responsables
qui assument une responsabilité au qui
monte en projet pour nourrir les débats
étaient donc de façon très concrète qui
ça nous a demandés notamment des 6 3
après une sortie sillage notamment des
types et éditeurs puissent l'agent de
l'assainissement vous fait qu'ils sont
arrivés fin de semaine on n'a qu'à
comprendre même senti centimes pour
atteindre café à l'aube à trac on pense
à mes faux les abonnés qu'on pense à nos
cafés nous kaboom est pourquoi nous
n'irons adpi propre le cagou main de
façon très claire pour que au niveau
touristique nos incapacités digne un
pays merveilleux et nous cacher au togo
main pour que la martinique ni en
attrait pour cognant développement local
qu'a fait et c'est un élément important
et c'est un petit con tribution du cabba
qui intervient notamment dès qu'une
contribution solidaire pour nous réussit
à mettre en place un certain nombre de
chantiers qui se structurent un qui est
important dans le sud mais mcaffe votre
image hockey que nos pages un vini
pleurer devant la presse pour dire que
l'asm pas fait travailler puis par
balles ou des équipements quitté aux
normes mais c'est sa mort après des
mondes le responsable les élus la
personne
et puis les élus audigier a constaté qu
une responsable au parc après notre
dernier test répondre oui ou bien non
est ce que le secteur de l'eau pas coûté
ma tin classant secteur qui opaque
moment a constaté que nous ni secte le
côté public qui transparent
mais plus nous on est quand même
quelques difficultés de transparence et
puis l'eau privé merci juteux christine
directeur général d'audi ci d'avoir été
ce matin dans son crédit bonne journée